nicolas sarkozy on va aborder maintenant
les problèmes économiques c'est la fois
bien sûr l'emploi et puis les impôts les
35 heures au milieu de tout ça et les
retraites quand on regarde quand on dit
on se dit mais pourquoi il y arrive
et pourquoi nous on a des problèmes avec
nos entreprises est ce que soient les
chefs d'entreprises qui sont moins bon
est ce que c'est le pays qui est le
moins bon est ce que c'est le
gouvernement qui est le moins bon c'est
à ces satanés moyens actuellement le
phénomène moins d'impôts moins de
charges plus de liberté
l'invraisemblable façon dont les 35
heures ont été mis en oeuvre notamment
pour les pme de les sacrifier en la
matière par cette méthode aubry l'a
d'uniformes isme d'archaïsme une
suppression de dialogue voilà pourquoi
ils s'en sortent
la question difficile pour nous il
suffit pas qui est la croissance dans le
monde
la croissance est indispensable et on
l'a bien vu les quatre années où il ya
la croissance internationale le chômage
a reculé depuis un an où il ya plus la
croissance le chômage repart mais suffit
pas que la croissance dans le monde
il faut encore que nos entreprises et la
compétitivité pour prendre le plus
possible de cette part de croissance en
la question des charges sociales dans
notre pays est une question centrale
chaque fois qu'on à baisser les charges
sociales il ya un récent rapport une
série très intéressant qui montrent que
les allégements de charges de 93 à 97
ont créé 407 et par tous les économistes
le rapport à mai non mais je suis pas
les économistes de haut tout cas l'insee
existe un volet dit il c'est a contesté
ce rapport lui-même ne pourra pas avoir
peur pour continuer les coachs et alors
mais c'est déjà ça pardon n'est pas
l'université je dire excusez moi à me
fait continuer merci leleu merci
monsieur le professeur
si vous étiez mon élève vous n'auriez
pas fait ça révoltant mais mais je le
suis pas justement pas juste
c'est dommage car les mots donné
l'autorisation de continuer à vos
besoins mais ça se passe pas comme ça
chacun pouvant ses convictions la
question de l'allégement des charges est
une question centrale pourquoi parce que
chaque fois qu'on allège les charges on
rend le coût du travail moins cher et on
encourage les entreprises à engager les
plus jeunes ceux qui ont besoin d'un
emploi ou ceux qui n'ont pas de
qualification alors si c'est ça la voix
mais nicolas sarkozy pourquoi ce tour on
reste un allègement des sols c'est bien
alors on commence par le fait que depuis
97 la france à une croissance supérieure
à la moyenne européenne alors qu'avant
97 elle avait une croissance inférieure
à la moyenne européenne alors je veux
bien qu'on dise il faut faire s'il faut
faire ça toutes les mesures ont des
avantages inconvénients
la réalité c'est que de 93 à 97 vous
avez fait moins bien que nos voisins et
2,97 à 2002 nous avons fait mieux que ne
dit pas non tous nous tout le monde à
ces chiffres qui sont publiques
jeudi le soleil de cannes pardo est en
désaccord n'est pas sur les chiffres sur
les charbons la croissance à un chiffre
j'aime à leur demander votre avis alors
je vais vous donner exactement il suffit
ou les on a été les champions du monde
du prélèvement obligatoire et c'est pas
le sujet avant je dirais que la
croissance et 99 je vous parlais de la
croissance qui était le ministre des
finances s'est offert un joli ensemble
des sujets net on parle on parlera des
primes obligatoires après son ascension
les prélèvements obligatoires ils sont
aujourd'hui exactement au même niveau
qu'en 90 est exact alors que 97 il était
intimement au dessus en cas de 93
cependant vous étiez là ils ont augmenté
pendant côté elles sont restées stables
maintenant revenons à la fois c'est à
dire la croissance sur lesquelles le
gouvernement aurait lieu quatre années
de croissance et vous venez d'expliquer
aux téléspectateurs intéressés parce
qu'il est également contribuables et
qu'avec quatre années de croissance vous
n'avez pas fait reculer les impôts d'un
célèbre obligatoire c'est à l'heure
c'est ainsi
vous trouvez qu'un consensus comme la
sécurité vous rester raisonnable sur les
sujets économiques vous vous sentez bien
que la période qui vient de s'écouler a
été bonne pour la france arf 93-87 a été
mauvais vous devenez polémique tout le
monde sait dans tous les pays et pas
seulement en france les rapports du fmi
les journalistes tout le monde le sait
que 97 à 2002 la france ait une
croissance supérieure à ses voisins elle
a eu une croissance de 3 % la moyenne
européenne a été à 2,4 les années
précédentes à la une croissance
inférieure à ses voisins et ceux ci
c'est le résultat d'une politique car
c'est vrai que tout le monde où tout le
monde baisse en même temps ça c'est le
mouvement général m mieux que les
voisins ou moins bien que les voisins
c'est ce que la politique économique
peut faire alors là l'ancien de la
baisse des charges on la connaît par
coeur on la connaît par coeur celle là
recettes libérales magique dont les
français d'ailleurs n'ont jamais
tellement voulu parce que quand vous la
défendiez en 95 avec monsieur balladur
les français n'ont pas voulu quand vous
l'a défendu en 97 avec monsieur juppé
les français n'ont pas voulu
et quand vous la défendre en 99 pour
vous-même aux élections européennes les
français n'ont pas voulu non plus ça
marche savoir se faire mousser strauss
kahn ses professeurs la baisse des
charges sur les bas salaires a été utile
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas le sujet la
baisse des taches noires ça y est
nécessaire nous avions un coût du
travail sur les bas salaires supérieurs
à nos voisins
elle a été utile aujourd'hui ce n'est
absolument pas le sujet le sujet
aujourd'hui et de mettre en place des
moyens de la croissance moyen de la
croissance il repose beaucoup sur la
confiance est là de nouveaux ont rejoint
la crédibilité et la confiance car vous
savez il ya pas de baguette magique
quand j'étais me disais qu'à lui et des
challenges avait pas de baguette magique
pas plus que celle que pouvait avoir
monsieur arthuis monsieur alphandéry
avant sauf que les français ont eu
confiance qui est la création il ya une
l'innovation et nous avons eu plus de
croissance que nous voit ça et c'est
pour ça qu'il ya eu neuf cent mille
chômeurs de moins
alors que dans la précédente de la même
durée de la même durée mais aussi en
avance
objectif de lionel jospin la grande
mesure phare annoncée aujourd'hui c'est
900 millions d'euros a aussi créé dans
les cinq ans qui viennent comme une
mesure objective et un objectif atteint
- neuf cent mille chômeurs
mais heureusement nous avons une de sens
pratique et comment ferez vous moi nous
avons eu neuf cent mille chômeurs de
moins dans les cinq ans qui viennent de
s'écouler et nous fixons pour objectif
d'avoir neuf cent mille chômeurs deux
mois à nouveau dans les cinq ans qui
viennent
bon les moyens les moyens sont
évidemment d'arriver à soutenir la
croissance est de retrouver un rythme de
croissance de 3% ce qui nous paraît
possible
ce qui d'ailleurs visiblement paraît
possible à nos adversaires aussi
puisqu'il inscrit de la même manière
dans leur programme dans ces conditions
là ya pas de différence ce que nous
pensons c'est que l'effort doit être
principalement mis sur l'épreuve de
formation et ils seront mis sur le fait
que dans les années qui viennent
trois millions d'emplois vont être
libérés par des départs à la retraite
qui sont principalement des emplois
qualifiés et nous n'avons pas encore
aujourd'hui les gens pour les remplacer
se prennent de fin de formation de
qualification l'objectif que se donne
lionel jospin d'avoir ce un plus haut
qu'un jeune qui sortent du système de
formation sans qualification est un
objectif tout à fait majeur qui
d'ailleurs peut être partagée très au
delà des socialistes et de la gauche
et cet objectif là nous le tiendrons
parce que encore une fois il ya un
problème de crédibilité sur ce qu'ont
annoncé sur ce qu'on fait alors
formation professionnelle c'est quoi
c'est un compte épargne temps on peut
préciser un peu c'est l'idée que d'une
paille vous permettre à ceux qui n'ont
pas pu suivre les études des études
suffisamment longue quand il était jeune
de rattraper une sorte d'art d'avoir
douar droits de tirage et puis par
ailleurs ceux qui travaillent
d'accumuler grosso modo chaque semaine
de travail de donner lieu à un droit à
quelque chose qui ressemblera à une
heure ou une heure et demie de formation
c'est un droit nouveau qui est créé
c'est un droit qui doit permettre à
chacun de se reformer à un moment de sa
vie et ce système là nous en avons
aujourd'hui absolument besoin parce que
la qualification est au coeur de la
croissance
alors d'accord au moins avec cette
mesure c'est alors que surgit juste un
point d'histoire si dominique strauss
kahn veut bien l'accepter
la france a connu une période de
croissance qui a été tirée par la
croissance exceptionnelle et la
révolution technologique aux états unis
c'est un point d'histoire qui n'est
contesté par personne
j'en veux d'ailleurs pour preuve votre
auto satisfaction une autant plus
déplacé qu'on aurait besoin d'une
confirmation que les chiffres de 2001
sur le chômage
la dernière année que nous connaissons
sont révélateurs
le chômage total ou quoi pardo vous
croyez ça va venir
le chômage a augmenté de 0,2 pour cent
en france en moyenne dans les pays de la
zone euro il a reculé de 0,15 vous dites
que la france a fait mieux en matière de
chômage que les autres
c'est une erreur non pour ne pas
employer un mot plus fort j'en veux
également une autre preuve quand la
croissance internationale était là le
chômage a reculé en france comme
ailleurs
depuis un an où elle n'est plus là le
chômage augmente en france plus
qu'ailleurs
alors pourquoi souffrez que je dis ça ça
ne vous met pas en cause personnellement
ce sont des chiffres houssin alors
comment on peut faire pour s'en sortir
et quelles sont les spécificités vers
l'avenir parce qu'on peut faire du bien
contre habilement son nom mais c'est
pour essayer de comprendre sinon nous
pensons que l'allègement du coût du
travail est un élément incontournable
qui nous est de nous demander par tous
les entrepreneurs et notamment les
entrepreneurs industriels qui ont
beaucoup de main d'oeuvre une main
d'oeuvre qualifiée et main d'oeuvre
jeune jacques chirac propose que tout
jeune qui serait embauché un bac - 2
enfin à moins de bac plus 2 par une
entreprise
l'entreprise ne payerait pas de
cotisations sociales c'est une
différence essentielle est que les
socialistes avec les comprendre jeunes
ils ont envoyé les jeunes vers
l'administration pour une occupation
nous voulons envoyer les jeunes pères
l'entreprise avec un métier monsieur
jospin monsieur strauss kahn avait
promis 350 mille emplois dans
l'administration
trois cent cinquante mille emplois pour
les jeunes dans l'entreprise il ya eu
zéro emploi dans l'entreprise forcément
parce que quand monsieur jospin dit qui
va créer 900 milles on peut on se
demande bien quand un premier ministre
qui créent des emplois
le coût du travail est un élément
essentiel quand on décharge une
entreprise ça coûte 85 mille francs
quand on fait payer les 35 heures c'est
130 mille francs d'emplois et la
faillite
en la matière c'est pas l'inefficacité
de la baisse des charges qui marche
partout c'est les 35 heures
dont chacun s'accorde à reconnaître
aujourd'hui qu'ils n'ont pas créé les
emplois que martine aubry dian la preuve
et je termine par l'administration
sociale sur la nationale 6 à 400000
emplois créés par les 35 heures le
ministre des finances laurent fabius a
annoncé 225 milles entre deux ministres
du même du gouvernement
c'est du simple au double sur
l'information entre nous serait encore
voilà deux chiffres deux millions deux
cent mille chômeurs en france 900 mille
offres d'emploi insatisfaite
la formation professionnelle est
aujourd'hui inégale parce qu'elle
profite d'abord à ceux qui ont déjà une
formation et inefficace
cela représente des sommes considérables
nous souhaitons que chaque français
quelle que soit son parcours
quels que soient son âge et le droit à
une deuxième chance pour apprendre un
deuxième métier s'il est par exemple
victimes de licenciements économiques
alors on verra tout à l'heure comment on
finance tout ça parce qu'elle arrive
alors sur le premier point quand même
cette affaire de la baisse des charges
le cnpf dans les années 80 le medef
aujourd'hui il a toujours mis en avant
on connaît ça par coeur on en connaît
les mairies sur les bas salaires elles
ont eu lieu ces suppressions de charges
dont il ya plus de charges sur le sait
entre vous mais pas revenu d'ailleurs
sur les exigences plein nature et juppé
gens là nous en avons vous les savez
garder en avons rajouté sur les bas
salaires si c'était mauvais laissez moi
finir la mènera pardo vous était
tellement contre vous auriez pu les
jeunes veulent pas nous ingérer passe
sur les bas salaires sur les bas
salaires où il y avait un problème de
coût du travail les airs en charge ont
été utiles aujourd'hui elles ont disparu
le poids ne se pose plus le coût du
travail en france est à la moyenne
européenne
il n'est pas supérieur au coût du
travail en allemagne du coût du travail
en angleterre et donc c'est une sorte d'
ancien que vous reprenez tout le temps
comme c'était une sorte de baguette
magique que de croire que la baisse des
charges créer des emplois comme vous
l'avez dit très justement tout à l'heure
c'est demandée par tous les chefs
d'entreprises parce qu'évidemment leurs
problèmes à eux c'est de payer le
travail le moins cher possible
le problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui ce qui
a été fait en matière de baisse des
charges est arrivé à peu près à son
terme
on voit d'ailleurs très mal et j'ai vous
avez fait des déclarations il accueilli
hier en présentant avant-hier on peut
entendre le prendre jacques chirac était
très différente de celle d'alain juppé
et de ne surgisse nataf et primaire
l'occupé gravité
j'en expliquerai avec l'option savait
qui j'étais mais monsieur je trouve très
justement sur le fait de savoir si les
baisses de charges qui avait été donné
en échange des 35 heures seraient deux
seraient retirés ne serait pas retirée
j'ai lu dans la presse peut-être s'est
elle trompée que monsieur ruffenach
disent exactement le contraire de ce
cadre des 35 heures fixes s'arrangeront
entre les tu peux apporter mais voilà le
débat le débat le débat c'est de savoir
aujourd'hui si la politique qui a été
conduite de 87 de 97 à 2002 a permis de
faire plus de croissance que nos voisins
la réponse est oui si la politique qui a
été conduite et qui était principalement
à base de baisse des charges de 93 à 97
même si vous ne prenez pas votre charge
notez tout à l'heure ce qui était 95 97
et si ça a permis d'avoir une croissance
la supérieure à celle de base à la
réponse est non une fois qu'on a dit ça
on a beaucoup dit sur la qualité des
politiques qui ont été conduites
alors nicolas sarkozy 20 convienne sur
les 35 heures pour avancer pourquoi vous
dites faut aménager et pas supprimer les
35 heures si vous trouvez que c'est une
mauvaise mesure
pourquoi ne pas supprimer les 35 ans les
35 nerfs sur cette loi d'abord la
première conséquence des 35 heures ça
alourdit le coût du travail en france
n'est contesté par personne seule
alourdi de 11%
deuxièmement ça va peser très fortement
sur le pouvoir d'achat des salariés il
ya la moitié des salariés français qui
ont vu leur pouvoir d'achat stagner
parce que naturellement les entreprises
coincés avec les 35 heures n'ont pas pu
faire les augmentations de salaires
troisièmement ça pose un problème
d'organisation considérable chez les
deux millions deux cent mille petites et
moyennes entreprises
vous imaginez on peut pas remplacer les
gens comme cela quelle est la solution
les 35 heures peuvent être considérées
par certains de nos compatriotes comme
un progrès social et je suis tout à fait
d'accord sur le fait que la réduction du
temps de travail va dans le sens de
l'histoire
mais quelle est cette idée quand même
curieuse même monsieur strauss kahn
avait combattu en son temps à
l'intérieur du gouvernement de vouloir
empêcher ceux qui veulent travailler
davantage de pouvoir le faire il ya des
français qui veulent travailler moins et
on peut les comprendre mais il y en a
d'autres qui souhaitent travailler
davantage pour gagner davantage pourquoi
les en empêcher il faut rendre la
liberté de travailler et dans
l'entreprise y aura donc ceux qui
veulent rester aux 35 heures c'est la
durée hebdomadaire du travail et il ya
ceux qui voudront gagner davantage pour
travailler davantage pourquoi les eaux
non
et donc nous allons avec les partenaires
sociaux déplafonner le nombre d heures
supplémentaires
supprimer la surtaxation et sur le
dispositif aubry 2 comme extraordinaire
pour un gouvernement socialiste
qu'est ce que c'est que ce dispositif ça
consiste à subventionner chaque emploi
créé dans le cadre des 35 heures en
donnant quatre mille francs y compris
quand c'est un landreau quand c'est un
emploi de cadre sur kalinka quand ce que
nous voulons quand celle ci s'est chargé
c'est bien quand c'est la gorge mais
attention c'est malin du tout parce que
ce que vous croyez qu'il est intelligent
d'aller subventionné à 4000 francs 1
un homme ou une femme qui sortent à
chausser qui va dans une entreprise qui
fait 3 milliards d'euros de bénéfices
c'est absurde
le projet doit le savoir alors quand ça
vous gêne vous ajustez hermine et donc
on va reprendre ses 4000 francs que nous
allons recyclé dans une politique de
baisse des charges intelligente celle ci
qu'est-ce qui a besoin qu'on baisse le
coût du travail
ce sont nos compatriotes les moins
formés les plus jeunes ou ce parce que
c'est un vrai problème qui ont plus de
50 ans nous sommes le pays d'europe qui
avons le plus faible taux d'activité
pour les quinquagénaires cc public lors
qu'il faudra le reprendre sur ses soeurs
ses fans je crois bien les 850 ha
aménagés ou pas la loi votre avis on
peut toujours aménager une loi à la
question est de savoir si la droite veut
revenir ou pas sur les 35 heures en fait
elle s'est aperçue qu'elle ne voulait
pas revenir ce 35 heures car les
français sont attachés aux 35 heures
tous les sondages le monde d'ailleurs
c'est une pratique générale que vous
êtes toujours contre les mesures que
nous prenons mais lorsque d' aventure
vous venez au pouvoir on échange et
jamais qu'est ce que ça vous arrive
d'être battu excuses et déjà nous arrive
effectivement d'être bête ces douloureux
souvenirs de tours mais ça nous arrive
et lorsque nous sommes battus vous ne
revenez jamais dire que vous ne votez
jade mais vous avez toujours les moyens
jules vous revenez jamais sur les
mesures qu'on a prises pourquoi parce
que je vous ai expliqué si vous voulez
bien ses mots qu'est ce que c'est
possible
lorsque vous votez systématiquement avec
les mots les plus durs contre la
couverture maladie universelle d'un côté
contre le pacs de sujets différents
contre les 35 heures contre les emplois
jeunes mais lorsque vous davanture vous
revient au pouvoir ce qui est possible
car les élections sont jamais joué
d'avancé
vous dites on pérennisera les emplois
jeunes pourtant vous étiez très content
vous dites la cmu ou de l'évidence
on n'a pas encore parlé de ça restait
sur les 35 heures mal géré a déçu les 35
heures dont j'ai lu votre programme et
vous parlez de pérenniser pour les
emplois jeunes ce dont je vous félicite
ils se montrent que vous étiez très
content quand on les a voté non je viens
d'expliquer les gens poids jeunes en
entreprise mais c'est réseau par
messieurs sarkozy pérenniser les emplois
jeunes c'est pas parler de nouveaux
emplois jeunes c'est ce qui existe et il
faut d'ailleurs le faire donc vous avez
reste ans les 35 heures en fait vous
voulez remettre en cause des 35 heures
mais vous n'osez pas le dire parce que
quand vous dites que vous le ferez par
le dialogue et les syndicats ça n'a ni
queue ni tête
aucun syndicat ne veut renégocier les
accords qui ont été passés nous trouvons
aucun partenaire pour le faire est de
vous le ferez sans doute par la loi la
réalité de cette affaire l'arrêté cette
affaire c'est que les français sont
attachés aux 35 heures que contrairement
à ce que vous dites partout les 35
heures font qu'aujourd'hui la france
travaillent plus aujourd'hui la france
traille 27 milliards d'heures dans
l'année 2000 alors qu'elle travaillait
25 milliards d'heures en 97 venons 2
milliards d'heures de travail de plus et
donc tout l'argumentation sûr il faut se
soucier du travail qui est juste il faut
user du travail tombe à plat car nous
travaillons plus que nous travaillons
avant grâce notamment aux 35 heures la
réalité tout ça c'est que vous dites
avec un semblant de bon sens vous deviez
nice si on veut travailler plus pourquoi
est-ce qu'on travaillerait pas plus ceux
qui veulent travailler plus pour gagner
plus doivent pouvoir travailler plus
mais monsieur sarkozy qui choisit la
durée du travail dans l'entreprise
vous connaissez beaucoup de salariés qui
de l'entreprise peuvent imposer leur
durée du travail
c'est le patron qui choisit la durée du
travail c'est pas le salarié qui décide
s'il veut travailler plus si travailler
moi et cet argument vous employez c'est
celui qu'on a entendu tout au long de
l'histoire
j'en ai même une citation amusante ici
qui serait peut-être trop longue à lire
d'un député qui s'appelait bernard en
quand il s'agissait de ramener la durée
du travail quotidiennes à 12 heures il
est exactement ce que vous dites
il n'y a qu'à laisser faire travailler
plus de 12 heures ceux qui veulent
travailler 12h l'ouvrier dit il
il a envie de travailler le plus
possible heureusement que la loi empêche
de le faire car sinon jamais la durée du
travail n'aurait baissé on en serait
toujours à laisser les enfants
travailler jusqu'à 12 ans les mines
heureusement que la votre argument
l'argument libéral traditionnel ça fait
cent cinquante ans qu'on l'entend
heureusement de cet argument là a
toujours été combattue par la loi qui
empêche effectivement celui qui a la
liberté dans l'entreprise et qui est le
chef d'entreprise d'imposer la durée du
tram
qu'il veut à son salarié donc cette
fausse liberté vous mettez en avant
on voudrait être libre en voudrait
travailler plus la liberté d'entreprise
et pas le salarié qui l'a les caissières
de supermarché qui travaillent sur des
horaires décalés des emplois parfois à
mi temps imposés extrêmement difficile
c'est pas elle qui ont le choix de dire
je voudrais travailler à d'autres heures
je voudrais travailler un peu plus je
voudrais gagner un peu plus d'argent
la réalité c'est que toutes les lois de
réduction de la durée du travail depuis
un siècle et demi et que vous le savez
qui ont commencé avec mais en mettant
fin à des situations atroce notamment
sur le travail des enfants
toutes ces lois là ont dû apposer qu'on
ne puisse pas le dépasser même si
certains puis avoir quelqu'un voulait
travailler plus parce que sinon elle
serait jamais rentrés objections puis
question temps des questions qui s'est
enfin dit vraiment démissionne et
s'enfuie n'est pas ce que je suis je
suis désolé que ça vous agace au poste
bas c'est habituel socialistes flamands
on avait déjà eu le coup de jospin qui
nous avait fait il nous a expliqué qu'on
était les amis des esclavagistes
donc le coût du transit car issa
défendant la veuve de l'opprimé
c'est un coup bien classique vous avez
aimé les petites trompettes de halage
aurès on va revenir à aujourd'hui on est
en 2002 figure 1 2 passe en mode essence
et les arbres et bbb biensur n'ont pas
désarmé par les entreprises et bien
monsieur strauss kahn se fait pardonner
son image moderniste au parti socialiste
il a nous a fait un coup d'archaïsme on
aurait dit henri emmanuelli et mon point
de vue c'est pas un compliment
alors on va pour moi ça n'est pas la
voir revenir pour moi non plus
d'ailleurs
on va revenir à 2002 si vous le voulez
bien parce que vous êtes tellement gêné
sur ce qui se passe en 2002 on le dit la
même chose qu'à la neuvième saison
d'abord vous qui avez fait adopter les
35 heures par la loi
brutalement sans aucune discussion des
paramètres en cours de discussion
depardon en mettant par terre le
paritarisme
même madame nota on vient apporter un
jugement extrêmement sévère sur
l'incapacité de dialoguer de lionel
jospin
vous avez mis la démocratie sociale par
terre vous venez nous dire maintenant à
nous qu'il est impossible d'adapter les
35 heures pourquoi monsieur strauss kahn
voulait vous avec monsieur jospin
choisir à la place des salariés y ont à
mon problème mais maintenant personne ne
va choisir
salariés les électeurs désignent des
élus pour qu'ils prennent des décisions
ce comportement un peu dictatorial se
rappellerait le patronat du 19e siècle
méfiez vous de vos références alors
qu'elle était de faire l'imbécile fond
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire en la matière
la durée de madère du travail c'est 35
heures c'est la loi nous n'y reviendrons
pas est ce que ça vous va au moins comme
ça on s'évite un torrent d'inexactitudes
et on reste sur le concret
quel est le problème de l'économie
française aujourd'hui il faut soutenir
la consommation
donc il faut donner du pouvoir d'achat
aux français comment donner du pouvoir
d'achat aux français
il ya un certain nombre d'entreprises
qui ont des carnets de commandes pleins
et qui veulent donner des heures
supplémentaires est aujourd'hui
incroyable l'inspection est là pour voir
ceux qui travaillent trop et les
dénoncer et bien dans l'entreprise
sur la base du volontariat ceux qui
voudront faire des heures
supplémentaires c'est-à-dire au-delà de
leur hebdomadaire du travail à 35 heures
pour le faire y gagneront davantage
personne ne les obligera ils auront
choisi et nous nous disons que chacun
est libre de choisir sa virée parce que
celui qui ne veut pas les faire monsieur
strauss kahn ne les fera pas mais où est
ce que l'algérie m 2 avec ses 35 heures
vous avez vu ça dans une entreprise
qu'un salarié pouvait refuser les heures
supplémentaires
monsieur sarkozy que vous la connaissez
entreprises précitées non je vais
terminer dessus j'ai passé la direction
la route mais l'ami jouer et je vais
déjà me suis jetée bien sûr vous mais
vous savez les salariés qui nous
écoutent savent très bien
ils n'ont pas le loisir de choisir sur
brodeur monsieur strauss kahn on va
terminer sur ce point si vous le
permettez cambrai
cette vision arcade de la société tout
le monde au pas cadencé mais non
personne ne travaillons plus que les
autres il ya une durée de madère la
première question est ce qu'on la garde
oui deuxième question il ya des
entreprises qui ont besoin d'heures
supplémentaires pour retrouver de la
souplesse anglaise que les salariés ont
le droit de les faire oui
et à l'arrivée dur à ceux qui veulent
être aux 35 heures et qui resteront et
les autres qui veulent gagner davantage
parce qu'ils ont un problème de pouvoir
d'achat et qui pourront le faire quand
avec nous c'est la société du libre
choix renoncer à ce les avantages sans
les inconvénients
[Musique]